good morning Vietnam
I'm Greg Alba I'm John Humphrey we are
going to watch the trailer for fantastic
beasts the crimes of Grindelwald the
adventure continues this trailer is a TV
spots last feature rag got quite a few
requests for it so I says yes I really
got to rewatch the first one before this
one comes out you mean you don't
remember a lot of it yeah it's connected
to Harry Potter yeah before we do that I
want to say thank you to everyone who
has been following us on patreon yeah
beginning so many pledges lately I'm so
grateful for it over there we do weekly
Q&A and those are a lot of fun to shoot
as well as many a TV show reaction that
includes attack on Todd and my hero
academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood supernatural Gotham and a
Riverdale there's also some completed
shows on there already if you want to go
check out those watch along go to our
patreon Hey let's hop into this box
being in jail for a few months the
decision is made to move him
back to Europe where he has to answer
for the crimes that he is committees
never noticed the pollution these games
credence survives and decrees the big
question now
he's following the trail that will
didn't to me the reason everyone goes to
Paris really is creeps may not know who
easier but he needs to be found to find
oh there is enough threat as Grindelwald
mobilizes he's a master manipulator and
that is why he is so dangerous my
Bachelor Award
everyone's choosing sides becomes much
more dark and complicated and people's
allegiances to now being exposed take
in the world we're now getting into the
meat of the story and everything gets
darker and intricate whatever you think
you know
the case huh and get any of that
Creedence stuff from the truth no I mean
it was it sounds like to me is that
they're trying to get to Grindelwald
before Grindelwald gets greedy the
trailers have kind of made it seem like
it's all about getting Grindelwald and
crew dances back somewhere yeah yeah
remembering the first fantastic beasts
Creedence was like a really important
part wasn't throughout but he was a
major threat this actually makes sense
it really is strongly connected to the
of course I knew you after the beginning
to know that Creedence is important
cause like seeing the expansion of some
scenes and dialogue like even when Jude
Law and Steven Hawkings are talking to
each other and there's Newt Scamander
when they're talking with each other I'm
like there's a whole line about
Creedence that's kind of left out of the
other trailers but and they show that
scene and they just maybe this and
manipulate it it's a big you're talking
about carnival yeah sure they're talking
about both it's a safe house in London
and now I'm like there's a whole other
context that see yeah he's probably got
to get credence to that safe house at
first I thought I was like Oh Newt go
hide as much controversy as there is
surrounding Johnny Depp it certainly
looks like he's show like every shot
they show looks like he's showing up for
this movie I think he's gonna be a scene
stealer really yeah I do
he's just been waiting to get his hands
and powder action yeah well it does he
doesn't look over the top nor does he
look like he's not trying yes yeah even
though this trailer led me to go oh
maybe he's not the main thing about it
as a main part but seems like this is so
much about credence now of what was
established in the first fantastic piece
leading into here even that scene where
he's talking to a crowd of people like
doubt this trailer was making it even
clearer I think we should stop on the
trails yeah it's like nice to get a
little bit cleared up and now I would
like to maintain the rest of the mystery
if there's one thing I can gather from
JK Rowling I think she said it's gonna
be darker things have become much more
Tom what you don't say anything
don't ya darker than the earlier Harry
Potter film and darker than the last one
Wow I mean I think she said darker but
who knows I mean this is probably the
Empire Strikes Back - fantastic yeah
this is probably the wrath of God
fantastic this is probably the Dark
Knight no I can't wait for what the Dark
Knight Rises and fantastic beasts might
look like I'll be slightly disappointed
yes it's still ambitious enough to
appreciate you getting a clearer sense
of that they're talking about a war is
brewing talking about the different
allegiances more than just seeing
Grindelwald saying like cool lines and
maybe having a cool little gang it seems
like he will kind of have an army on his
side when he's talking to that group of
people I never really read much into
that scene but he's talking to that
large group of people and finding out
that there's probably some characters
who will be coming back from the first
one is why it's important to rewatch
them like coming back from the first one
who might actually have a hidden
allegiance to Grindelwald I'm guessing
okay that's gonna be nice commander's
brother he will be one of the reveals
because he wasn't in the first one so I
imagine that'll probably be a big deal
in here doing all that that's my guess I
know it's an obvious twist but I don't
think this movie will surprise me with
not having that twist yeah and I guess
the only other thing I am wondering now
is like what is gonna really separate
this from Harry Potter as its own thing
because you know part of me worries like
is Grindelwald just gonna become other
Voldemort we have a lot of similar
quandary for the characters to figure
out about allegiances and you know dark
wizardry versus light wizardry and you
know I don't know how muggles figure in
all this stuff now we're in uncharted
territory and fantastic beasts as a book
is literally an encyclopedia and none of
this is it having her writing this movie
intrigues me because it seems like she
was the last one yeah yeah and I liked
the aesthetic like I liked the last one
but it didn't like leave a heavy impact
on me from a story perspective I thought
a lot of the characters a lot of the set
pieces some of the ideas did overall you
know this seems like a weightier version
and now I just you know hope that it's
fresh as well because I've seen
Wizarding war
for I have a prediction that most of the
beasts from his briefcase are gonna die
oh really
yeah I think in order to make this
franchise work in this tale they are
telling us they want to do like five of
these or something really sad like some
crazy amount of movies you know for some
pretty cool we took the last script and
then we broke in half into two I think
that it has to get more personal rather
than just intriguing because I mean you
brought up Voldemort and a big part of
what made that work was the personal tie
it has to Harry Potter yeah in terms of
Voldemort killed Harry's parents so you
got this build up of them finally having
lacklustre duel in the last movie but
you still have that build up and that
intrigue I don't think they'll kill off
Grindelwald in this movie I don't know
if the contract is a giant up has for
this movie I'm sure you guys probably
know if he's signed on for like 18
movies or whatever account that just
tracks people's contract I think this
might end in a way to where he won't
need to come back he can just be Colin
Farrell crating cycle movies you know we
can do that the main thing that these
trailers have given me because you like
I'm a big Harry Potter fan I grew up on
this stuff and the one thing that never
fails about these fantastic beast
trailers is just the striking images
like that moment with all those like
shrouds floating up I think the one
thing that that keeps me excited about a
Harry Potter cinematic universe yeah
is the aesthetics of the world it's like
even if there's a lackluster story and I
feel like this is a world that I just
like to spend time in so I've always got
that to look forward to and seeing some
of the images in this trailer I can't
imagine that that stuff will not be
super satisfying you know image really
stood out to me in this trailer which
image JK Rowling's I will I don't think
I've ever noticed just how strivers she
wearing contacts Wednesday like punch up
her eyes her eyes are like strikingly
blue here and I don't remember
interviews I've seen with her but
man like here it's like out of the ocean
that I don't know if they did that here
but they do that in post-production well
they will enhance people's eyes like
they'll make them brighter Evan in
lesser movies you'll see people have
like glowing lights and stuff oh man
she's hot too she's come on together
yeah like she's like 69 this year I'm
not sure but I could imagine yeah I'm
just saying that to upset you yes you
bookworms I'm just saying the only age
you could think of how could you forget
that yeah that's my house my real guess
yeah I don't think she's 69 I would be
very surprised she is well done what's
your secret well she's 69 s that's her
seat appreciating that comment their
book works
JK Rowling she's 53 okay 50s that makes
sense and that's hot
I thought she was hot or I thought she
was in her 60s listen before we wrap
this up I want to get a quick shout out
to a man named Curt Anderson Curt
Anderson we've shouted out before I
haven't talked to you in like a little
over a month buddy I'm kind of concerned
at this point because I wanted you to
let me know how the surgery went this
guy travels the world is a nomad he had
some incident where he had a really bad
rupture in his ear then he showed me a
video of the surgery they were gonna do
which was the appreciate you said we
recorded a reactive it a beautiful that
was not good at all you're like I've
defeated cancer this will be nothing I
haven't heard from you I think I saw a
comment on one of our youtube videos
this week I'm assuming you can hear us
I'm assuming you can see us I'm assuming
you're fine but I would like a message
to confirm that please Curt yeah once
you're done in the infirmary once Madam
Pomfrey is done fixing you up miss you
Kurt shoot me a message but guys you can
subscribe to the reject nation please
click that notification bell you know
why and check us on patreon we got TV
show reactions q and A's John does music
coverage I occasionally guest star on
those yeah we got plenty of goodies
check us out